You okay
what is grief if not love persevering
part of the madness of the multiverse is we
get to see different realities and we see
different versions primarily of doctor strange
but we do see other versions of wanda maximov
i think wandavision was this journey of her
for the first time taking her own life into her
own hands and it was fun transitioning from her
experience to this movie you could use an avenger
there are other avengers i'll get you back in the
lunchbox what do you know about the multiverse
we wanted to satisfy the wandavision fans and take
them to the next level with a character they loved
it was fun just looking at it from a different
perspective the multiverse this had his theories
he believed it was dangerous we need your help
it's magical she owns that character so
well it's a very powerful performance with
a very powerful character in the multiverse
there are alternate versions of everyone
it gives the characters unique
opportunity to meet themselves
to recognize qualities that they may have been
blind you the fate of the multiverse depends on us
london i could use an avenger this is
going to be fun in five days the madness
begins i don't even want to know
Welcome back everyone this will be my brand new Doctor Strange 2
trailer video there's a
whole bunch of new footage wong is just completely
done with all this doesn't he wish he went on a
vacation way back during spider man no way home
because the movie's coming out next week i'm doing
a giveaway for imax tickets all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and just leave your
favorite new moment from the trailer on the video
my non-spoilery review is supposed to post tuesday
morning sometime after they allow us to post them
make sure you have alerts enabled for my channel
so you don't miss that because it is going to be
crazy and do not wait to go see this movie see
it as soon as possible because it is going to
wreck the mcu in the best possible way but
just starting at the beginning with this
really cool clip of them traveling across a
bunch of different universes there are a bunch
of easter eggs you probably spotted some of the
more obvious ones too but the funny thing that's
happening here is they're traveling through these
different universes is that they start screaming
originally when they're traveling and they just
continue screaming because the physical properties
in different universes different dimensions are
different their scream changes pitch changes style
as they go through different dimensions like they
just continue screaming but it sounds different
because it's so different in other universes
the first one is that block looking minecraft
universe i'm sure new master will eventually
take over that dimension given enough time
all the game themed dimensions inside the mcu
multiverse the second one is the paint themed
color dimension where they basically just turn
into living paint versions of themselves with
a bunch of different colors sloshing around the
sloshing sounds is their screen continuing but
because they're paint it sounds like sloshing
but they're still screaming while it's happening
the third one is the black and white dimension
set during the 1920s 1930s in the looney tunes
laughing sound that you're hearing as they
travel through it is actually their scream
just changing pitch as they're traveling through
that universe you see the really old classic cars
the people from that era you could think of this
as the spider-man noir dimension because he is
from the 1930s and we're talking about a marvel
production here but because of that very specific
sounding roger rabbit looney tunes laugh and
because this is disney that we're talking about
looney tunes is warner brothers but disney
obviously had their own version of that
this old timey black and white universe might
be a reference to the origin of mickey mouse
which is in the late 1920s which would be around
this area where you're seeing all this happen
like they're literally traveling through the
steamboat willie universe and this is meant to
be a reference to the origin of mickey mouse at
disney because disney owns marvel but just to
explain how they can travel seemingly back in time
and there are some universes that are set in the
far future too the reason why it seems like they
can time travel even though they're just laterally
moving through different dimensions like they're
just walking through doors they kind of explained
this during the loki's series the timelines of
these alternate universes aren't meant to line
up one to one so in some universes for example the
big bang doesn't start till later in the timeline
in some universes it starts sooner than it does
during the mcu so right now in the mcu it might
be 2024 but even though the same amount of time
would have passed in these alternate universes
it might still be the year 2024 in that universe
but because the big bang happened earlier in the
timeline that means that humans evolved much
faster iron man and the others talked about
this during avengers end game when they use their
special tech inside the quantum realm to control
their travel through different universes different
timelines because they said that if things went
wrong they could wind up in any random time period
in any random alternate universe the next universe
is meant to be a version of earth and present day
in which the kree empire had taken over the earth
years ago like all this is cree architecture all
around then they travel into a universe where the
earth looks like it's in its far future it looks
kind of like the blade runner version of new york
the closest reference would be to like a
spider-man 2099 version of nueva york which
we actually did see in the spider-man across the
spider-verse trailer and he's being played by a
version of oscar isaac who are actually watching
on moon knight in live action right now in the mcu
so talk about easter eggs then they travel to
another version of earth that looks all sleek
and modernized but not quite as far in the future
like the tech seems totally different but it's not
blade runner looking so it's just an earth that
set a little bit in the future then this next
universe looks kind of like a star wars revenge of
the sith mustafar reference we'll call it the high
ground universe the earth in present day is just a
pile of molten rock like humans didn't evolve here
maybe there are no buildings or anything in the
background so it's likely in this universe that
their timeline the big bang doesn't happen until
way later and humans just have not evolved yet in
this universe or i guess you could say this is a
universe where the celestial successfully hatched
tiamit so it broke apart inside the earth and this
is just the remains of a giant chunk of the earth
then the last universe where they land on the
rooftop when everything looks all lush and green
in the background it looks like this idealized
version of earth is america chavez's original
earth that she came from this is meant to be the
same universe where defender strange came from
we're gonna see it at the beginning of the movie
i believe i explained that in a previous video so
i won't repeat that but the way the producers
explained her power during the movie is that
she's still really young and she doesn't totally
understand how to control it so she can only open
portals between different dimensions when she has
really extreme emotional states so her ability is
kind of like the way the hulk's ability worked
early on in his timeline before he created the
professor hulk before he kind of worked it out
in his mind then there's a ton of footage of
scarlet witch with billy and tommy in a version
of westview they confirmed that this is meant
to be a dream sequence that mcu scarlet witch is
having when she talks about the nightmare she has
every morning but it's also meant to be a legit
alternate universe like it's really happening
but it's still a dream sequence that she's having
in the movie they call dreams the windows to
alternate universes so she's seeing what's
happening in an alternate version of westview with
an alternate version of herself with a version
of billy and tommy who are still alive and still
with her later you see that version of her look
directly into camera like she's kind of looking
at herself but it's also the variant of scarlet
witch realizing what's happening because she also
has all the chaos magic and she's the version that
goes off the rails that we see in that illuminati
base with like all that blood and oil all over her
r.i.p illuminati when she talks about having fun
transitioning from her experience in wandavision
versus during this movie she's talking about
scarlet witch just actively deciding to use the
darkhold and her chaos magic to find a version of
billy and tommy and bring them back to the mcu
that was what was happening in the wandavision
post-credits scene vision is also probably part
of that equation but i believe that mcu scarlet
witch is aware of white vision what's going on
with him and that he's basically her vision just
without a lot of the emotional context for all the
memories that he just got unlocked inside him but
he doesn't really have the emotional connection to
the twins because all the billy and tommy memories
were actually made by hex vision and hex vision
really just unlocked white vision's original
memories pre-dating the hex really scarlet witch
created all of this out of nothing she created
the version of vision that she had the children
with who she also created that's how powerful
she's meant to be in the movie that she can
do crazy stuff like that this is footage of
scarlet witch inside the mcu attacking a version
of kamartage then in the snow here i think this
is all part of the darkhold temple battle scene
with the attack from the marvel zombies version of
defender strange where everybody just goes crazy
like this is getting ridiculous i love wong in
this moment where he's just like i don't even want
to know what's going on with you you seem crazy
i don't even want to know the funny thing is
that even though scarlet witch seems kind of
like one of the big antagonists of the film
a lot of the problems that are happening here
are very spider-man home style problems where
spider-man for example in the spider-man movies
usually causes most of the problems that he
winds up having to solve in this movie it's the
same thing with mcu doctor strange where he is the
person who uses the dark hole to open doors to the
multiverse which leads to a lot of this craziness
happening even though given enough time scarlet
witch herself would have done the same thing but
if you spotted any big easter eggs in the brand
new footage that i didn't talk about in the video
just write them below in the comments like i said
my non-spoilery review will post tuesday morning
my full moon knight episode 6 finale video will
also post wednesday just like normal all my doctor
strange spoilery videos the easter eggs post
credit scenes all that stuff we'll start posting
after the movie actually comes out next week i'll
name a giveaway winner in my next big marvel video
everyone click here for my brand new moon knight
episode 6 finale trailer video and click here
for my brand new doctor strange 2 x-men video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!